المخلب السيف مستمره لايام ام شهور اخر
حدود العمليه العسكريه التركيه في الشمال
السوري لن تكون جغرافيه فحسب التوغل البري
وارد جدا ولكن دون تاريخ محدد تريد انقر
حزما امليا من الغرب الى الشرق والغره
الجويه مستمره منذ سته ايام هدفها اقامه
تلك المنطقه اوضح الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان العمليه البريه الموعوده والمؤجله
الى الوقت المناسب وفق توقيت انقر السياسي
والعسكري ستشمل تل رفعت ومنبج وعين العرب
كوباني اي استكمال المنطقه الامنيه التي
يبلغ عمقها 30 كلم على طول الحدود
الجنوبيه ومن كل منبر ترسل تركيا رسائل
وعيدا جديده هذه المره فعاليه في اسطنبول
خاصه بمكافحه العنف ضد المراه
التي تريح الدماء في بلادنا وتقتل النساء
والاطفال هم شركاء في اراقه الدماء
والوحشيه التي تحصل والجرائم ضد الانسانيه
التي ترتكب
التي تصريحاته بشان سير العمليه العسكريه
قال وزير الدفاع التركي خلصي اكار ان
326 ارهابيا على حد تعبيره قتلوا في
الغارات الجويه والقذف المدفعي نفس اهدافه
القوه التركيه مدنيين او نقاط تابعه لقوه
التحالف خلال تلك العمليه
تلقوا اذكار جاء ردا على حديث البنتاجون
الاربعاء الماضي عن تهديد العمليات
التركيه سلامه العسكريين الامريكيين في
شمال السوري بنظر واشنطن الوضع المتساعد
يعرض للخطر ما تسميه التقدم الذي تحقق على
مدى سنوات ضد تنظيم الدوله يوجد حاليا
قرابه 900 جندي امريكي في سوريا تحديدا في
شمالها الشرقي يعملون مع قوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه لمحاربه فنون تنظيم الدوله
مخاوف وعشره
في خطط انقر الحاليه والمستقبليه عن عمليه
عسكريه اوسع يتحدثون هذه المره يحرصون على
التذكير ان تامين الحدود عن طريق ممر
امنيا لن
يتعارضاني وحده اراضي كل من سوريا والعراق
كان فيما تسمى وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
ضلوعها في تفجير شارع الاستقلال باسطنبول
نفيون تنفيه انقره عين التركيه على عين
العرب كوباني هل التوغل البري مساله ايام
فقط